imagine that you're a black 25 year old
Community College student living in
Alabama you're struggling to pay your
bills and you live with your parents and
let's also assume that you're also not a
particularly ethical person so in
desperation you start thinking about
robbing the spa where you work part-time
you even Google Search terms like how to
steal money from a cash register without
getting caught
first tip is uh don't Google it that's
the first way to not get caught a little
late for that now
that's how Bleak things are though for
you so what do you do next systemic
white supremacy won't let you get a
better job or make more money you know
how that is so uh what can you do if
you're a member of the bipop community
who needs cash and validation fast but
you aren't getting either of those
things do you rob a bank
do you make up some sob story and try to
get on American Idol what do you do
according to the experts who have
studied this question for a long time
there's one thing you definitely should
not do and that's fake your own
kidnapping because if you did that you'd
never get any kind of attention or raise
any amount of money because Americans
are so racist that they wouldn't care
about your disappearance as the
Washingtonian put it recently quote
missing black people don't receive
widespread media coverage the Harvard
political review double checked that
finding and they agreed with it quote
missing black and Indigenous people do
not receive the same attention in public
support as white women with similar
stories The Washington Post
independently looked at all the
available evidence and they concurred
with Harvard they reported that quote
the media loves missing white women
black women are already missing from
public View
that's true I mean you'd just you'd
never see any black women anywhere ever
not in media nowhere
totally true
so the expert consensus is clear if
you're a person of color quote unquote
specifically the black color then don't
pretend to get kidnapped for attention
it would be uh pretty embarrassing
actually like when someone quits their
job and no one at work even notices
that's how evil this country is
now if there are any experts or
left-wing activists who really believe
any of that then the drama that played
out over the week the past week in this
country must have come as a tremendous
shock to them because here's the recap
in case you missed it on July 13th the
black community college student named
Carly Russell suddenly disappeared
Russell called 9-1-1 while driving on
the interstate and she said that she was
she said she was following an abandoned
toddler who was walking along the road
for some reason
she told the dispatcher that she
followed this toddler in her car for
about 600 yards
this toddler was walking along the
interstate for 600 yards and then Carly
Russell called her brother's girlfriend
and then got out of her car to save the
child at which point
she screamed into the phone and vanished
very dramatic
what happened next
presumably based on the expert Insight
from Harvard and the Washington Post the
story would just disappear into the
ether just like Carly Russell herself no
one would ever mention the name Carly
Russell ever again nobody would care
that's the expected result for the
scholars what actually happened is that
the entire news media lost its
Collective mind and covered Carly
Russell's disappearance Non-Stop
here's just as one example a package
from the local NBC station which aired
within a day of Carly's disappearance
and here's what they say about
a woman in Hoover near Birmingham has
vanished after spawning a toddler alone
near the side of the inner
25 year old Carlita Russell was on the
phone with her family when they heard
her scream and then nothing else even
though her phone stayed on the line her
car was found near the spot where she
reported the toddler that's where we
find Patsy Douglas from our NBC
affiliate in Birmingham
this is where Carly was last seen here
on i-459 near John Hawkins Parkway in
Hoover on Thursday evening police say
Carly called 9-1-1 saying a toddler was
walking down the side of the interstate
after calling police she stopped to get
the child and called a family member
when police arrived they found her car
and belongings nearby but no sign of her
or the child family member is now on the
search for Carly her parents desperate
for her return to keep applying the
pressure to keep this thing going we
really want this to blow up we want the
word of the day to be Carly
hmm
we really want this to blow up says
Carly's family and blow up it did it
wasn't long before media reports
indicated that a witness had seen a
vehicle with a male with a light
complexion near the scene of the crime
which makes sense because white people
are always out hiding in the woods
sending out toddlers as bait to Lauren
black community college students it
happens all the time
that version of events checked out with
ABC News in their rigorous editorial
standards ABC ran this package as the
search for Carly continued watch
police in Alabama are searching for a
woman who vanished under strange
circumstances after she stopped to help
a child she saw walking all alone along
an interstate 25 year old Carlita Nicole
Russell called 9-1-1 then a family
member about and told a family member
about the child police say that family
member on the phone lost contact with
Russell even though the line remained
open responding officers then found
Russell's car but her not her phone
and oh nor the child
now notice that ABC like NBC just comes
out and assumes the Carly's story is
true they report as if it's beyond
dispute the Carly quote stopped to help
a child she saw walking all alone along
the interstate I'll tell you there's a
real missing child out there without
verifying it in any way
that's remarkable for a few reasons but
the main reason is it's remarkable is
that it makes absolutely no sense
for one thing the interstate where Carly
Russell pulled over wasn't some desolate
stretch of Country Road there are a
bunch of cars and trucks driving by at
the time of her supposed kidnapping
here's footage of Carly pulling her car
over and you can see it here and what
you see there in the footage is that you
know many vehicles are driving by as
Carly puts her hazards on to find the
Phantom missing child
why did none of the drivers of any of
those Vehicles call 9-1-1
why was Carly Russell the only person
who seemed concerned that a toddler was
somehow managing to run 600 yards down
the side of an interstate at night I
mean that's the kind of thing that
people will notice
however there's no evidence of any kind
of struggle once she pulled over Why did
no witness see her being abducted
before we could get answers to any of
those questions a couple days later if
you can believe it Carly showed up at
her parents house totally unharmed she
told detectives that a white man with
orange hair had kidnapped her then took
photos of her naked before she escaped
Carly's boyfriend meanwhile posted on
social media that she had to fight for
her life in order to secure her freedom
then shortly afterwards he took down
that post for reasons that remained
unclear
at this point if you're not deranged or
hopelessly naive you're probably getting
a little suspicious but rather than
question any of this the Today's Show on
NBC held a sympathetic exclusive
sit-down interview with Carly's parents
and it was just like if you remember
that Robin Roberts interview the
infamous one with Jesse Smollett back in
the day where the deeply concerned
reporter nods as she's fed obvious lies
so here are some highlights from this
latest version of that kind of interview
watch
that moment you all first laid eyes on
her again
what was it like
to me I mean just so much joy this
morning and an exclusive sit down with
NBC News the parents of 25 year old
Carly Russell are speaking out
describing the moment their daughter
appeared on their doorstep after being
missing for more than 48 hours her
parents declined to share what their
daughter told them citing the ongoing
investigation and can you tell me what
happened Saturday night did you just get
a knock at the door anything leading to
to the chase itself we we can't discuss
that but they say speculation about the
circumstances surrounding Carly's
disappearance or only making things
worse she's having to deal with the
trauma of people just making completely
false allegations about her and when I
talk to you all on Saturday you also
said your daughter is a fighter and she
would find a way back to you
I felt that in my heart is that what
happened she did she found her way back
to us however
we can't discuss the details of that but
they say one thing is clear do you
believe she was fighting for her life
she definitely there were moments when
she physically had to fight for her life
and there were moments when she had to
mentally fight for her life
mentally fighting for her life she
should have done a lot more mental
fighting before this whole plan was
hatched I think so the parents
definitely can't talk about the case for
some reason but they can say even though
they're sitting down for an interview so
you know for an interview about the case
but we can't talk about the case okay
what they can say is that they they
don't want you to say anything they
don't want you to say anything about how
strange and totally unbelievable their
daughter's story is because that's
inflicting trauma
on her daughter and on all of them
but the mother can say that her daughter
had to mentally fight for her life
whatever that means
the bottom line is that they want you to
know that they're the victims
is that true well shortly after the
interview we learned that Carly had been
running some pretty suspicious Google
searches on her phone the day of her
disappearance apparently Carly stole
some stuff from her job and then Googled
a well-known action movie about a
woman's kidnapping the uh the movie
Taken uh with Liam Neeson which by the
way in that movie uh if you remember
Liam Neeson's daughter was on the phone
and then she let out a scream when she
was kidnapped which is the same thing
that happened with Carly Russell
allegedly
my question I don't know the person that
was on the phone with Carly Russell did
that person then give a speech about how
he's a particular set of skills and he
will find you and kill you I I don't
know
she also searched for information about
Amber Alerts ahead of time
she had a premonition she had a
premonition she was going to go missing
so she looked up Amber Alerts
and when cops wanted to talk to her for
some follow-up questioning they haven't
been able to get in touch with her
maybe the white man in orange hair
kidnapped her again
police say that there's no evidence that
any part of Carly's story is true they
haven't been able to confirm any part of
it at all yet the media is still
reluctant to point in the direction of
the obvious truth here which is not the
whole thing obviously he's a hoax
uh even the local police chief is too
afraid to come out and say that here was
his statement quote we want to talk in
facts and I do think it's highly highly
unusual to the day that someone gets
kidnapped that's several seven hours or
eight hours before that they're
searching the internet Googling the
movie take it about an abduction I find
that very very strange he says well
there you have it it's very very strange
well actually it's not very strange at
all it's totally predictable when you
transform victimhood into a currency
when you reward the most unserious and
corrupt people for their behavior then
you get more corruption
now I'm going into some detail here
about all of this because it illustrates
something that's not talked about enough
what we're seeing in this case and so
many others
is pathological lying from virtually
everyone in the media and government the
powers that be they don't just play on
our fears for Ratings or clicks instead
they actively generate false fears in
order to distract us from the things
that we should be worried about
black women are getting kidnapped
randomly by white terrorists who use
toddlers as bait
they basically just spend the last week
saying almost exactly that
they're doing this right out in the open
and they're not ashamed of it we're days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to the US Dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd brics nations are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities is
part of their long-term plan to supplant
America and the dollar as cornerstones
of the Global Financial system you can
protect your IRA or 401K from The
Fallout of this Landmark Announcement by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have well you can protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
you can find out why by texting Walsh to
989898 and get your free info kit on
gold of a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it'll be nice to have
some gold to depend on again text Walsh
to
989898 you know what companies looking
out for you when they actually upgrade
your service and don't charge you for it
this is great news for new and current
customers pure talk just added data to
every plan and includes a mobile hotspot
with no price increase whatsoever if
you've considered pure talk before but
haven't made the switch take a look
again for just twenty dollars a month
you'll get unlimited text talk and now
fifty percent more 5G data plus their
new mobile hotspot as well this is why I
love Pure Talk they're veteran owned and
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while also enjoying the
most Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com Wallace puretalk
Wireless for Americans buy Americans
CNN just published what they call a news
article that's the perfect example of
this kind of thing here's the first
sentence of this objective news item
quote mass shootings and major
metropolitan areas in the United States
disproportionately affect black people
and structural racism may play a role
the authors complain uh in the study
that quote racial and ethnic minority
populations are significantly more
likely to be victims of mass shootings
according to CNN quote the study found
that in areas with higher black
populations mass shootings are likely to
occur compared to communities with
Higher White populations there are also
more black people injured and killed
wind mass shootings take place according
to the findings
now the message is that blacks in the
city should be worried about racism
because of all the mass shootings and
what of course they don't mention is
that the overwhelming majority of the
so-called mass shootings in cities are
perpetrated by black people or Hispanics
on occasion
and that's almost everyone who's
committing mass shootings in cities
you don't have to guess about that
either New York Times ran the numbers a
few years ago they looked at every
single mass shooting event that's
occurred in the United States everywhere
not just in the cities
um and that was in 2015 and roughly 75
percent of all the mass shootings
were perpetrated by black people
of course CNN doesn't say that anywhere
in the article instead they tell scary
ghost stories about systemic racism
so that we don't focus on the very real
problem of the black community killing
itself
and they cite experts as cover so they
don't have to reckon with the obvious
absurdity of all of this
all they care about is generating the
fear the false fears about things that
don't exist
it's not just the media that's doing
this this is a social cancer and
therefore it's much bigger than
corporate media it's endemic and
politics as well you might have seen uh
that Democrats just ran an ad that's
gotten a lot of attention and this is an
ad in Ohio
and in the ad they're claiming that
Republicans want to take away birth
control
they made an advertisement that was you
know intentionally very salacious and
also dishonest uh because it's supposed
to generate all this attention which it
successfully did but here's the ad
do you have a condom
you can't use those what are you talking
about who are you I'm your Republican
Congressman now that we're in charge
we're Banning birth control this is our
decision not yours get out of our
bedroom I won the last election I'm not
going anywhere I'm just gonna watch and
make sure you don't do anything illegal
some great acting there as well
phenomenal now not that it needs to be
said but there is no effort in Ohio or
any other state to ban birth control
this is an entirely delusional concern a
fear based in nothing but their own
imaginations on the left
the truth is that most conservatives
won't even speak honestly about the
dangers of birth control though they
should much less try to ban it
the bill they're talking about in that
ad it's prop one
and guess what it has nothing to do with
birth control at all
it's about the procedural requirements
needed in order to pass an amendment to
the state constitution that's what the
bill is
so why are Ohio democrats lying about
prop one and Republican supposed scheme
to Outlaw birth control
they're warning about evil Republicans
coming to steal your birth control so
you don't focus on other things and when
it comes to birth control they don't
want you to focus on the fact that
basically everything STDs divorce rates
unwed pregnancies has gotten worse since
birth control was invented take a look
at the divorce rates from 1965 and 1975
sometime divorce rate doubled five years
after the pill was first made available
again they're feeding you invented
problems you don't notice the real ones
they're giving you fake things to be
afraid of so you don't worry about the
real threats
Hollywood and entertainment writers do
the same thing the Atlantic magazine
just published a think piece on the new
Barbie movie and we're getting a lot of
think pieces about Barbie this one is
entitled what's the matter with Barbie
Greta gerwig's Barbie is a Charming
Blockbuster Adventure about the
tribulations of Simply existing as a
woman in society
yes the tribulations of Simply existing
as a woman in modern American society
left unmentioned in this article is that
men kill themselves at more than three
times the rate of women they overdose
far more often as well according to the
CDC data as of 2021 men have a life
expectancy United States of just 73
years old whereas women typically live
until 79. as Harvard Medical School put
a quote men die younger than women and
they're more burdened by illness during
life they fall ill at a younger age and
have more chronic illnesses than women
for example men are nearly 10 times more
likely to get hernias than women and
five times more likely to have aortic
aneurysms American men are about four
times more likely to be hit by gout
they're more than three times more
likely than women to develop kidney
stones to become alcoholics to have
bladder cancer they're about twice as
likely to suffer from uh
emphysema or
ulcers although women see doctors more
often than men men cause their society
much more for medical care beyond age 65
when it comes to health males are the
weaker sex throughout life that's what
they said
although calling it The weaker sex is
obviously not a fair characterization so
even when we're listing all of the
illnesses that men get there's the
there's a take a shot at men at the end
of it
now you're not supposed to think about
that just like you're not supposed to
think about what's actually happening in
Black communities or what birth control
actually does to women or why struggling
black community college student would
lie about being kidnapped
you're also not supposed to think about
the testimony of those IRS
whistleblowers or the FBI documents
showing that Joe Biden has personally
implicated an illegal overseas influence
peddling operations there's a media
blackout in all those topics
every Power Center in this country is
willing to lie to to your face as
obviously as they possibly can to keep
you from thinking any of these
unapproved thoughts
to keep you afraid of the Phantoms
they've created
you know one of the reasons why hoaxes
like the Carly Russell case gained so
much traction and seem apparently
believable to so many people at least at
first is that the media has laid the
groundwork by telling us about an
epidemic of hate crimes against black
people and other supposedly marginalized
groups
but it's all a lie there's there is no
such epidemic
you only need to look at the numbers to
see the lie for what it is for instance
when they insist as they often do that
trans people are being murdered in hate
crimes by the dozens every year one
quick look at the stats shows that in
order to support that assertion they're
categorizing literally every single
murder of a trans person as a hate crime
even though the data indicates that
maybe one or two of the victims each
year are killed for being trans
not much of an epidemic
but the pathological lying is right out
in the open now the only good news here
is that pathological lying is the
easiest kind of line to spot and it's
the easiest kind of lying to reject
therefore
what's needed is for people in power to
actually do that to reject this Insanity
because if they don't
then you know more desperate lunatics
will start running into the woods
pretending to be kidnapped
they'll take advantage of every
weak-willed police chief and every
corrupt media Outlet in this country
we're already seeing that happening
it'll happen more often
until it happens constantly until you
can't get away from it
lies will become indistinguishable from
reality once that happens you don't have
civilization anymore you have something
unrecognizable something that you can
never repair hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there